No matter how long it may take us...
...to overcome this premeditated invasion,...
...the American people in their righteous might,...
...will win through to absolute victory.
In the long history of the world,...
...only a few generations have been granted the role of defending freedom...
...in its hour of maximum danger.
I do not shrink from this responsibility.
I welcome it.
The energy, the faith, the devotion, which we bring to this endeavor,...
...will light our country and all who serve it,...
...and the glow from that fire can truly light the world.
And so, my fellow Americans,...
ask not what your country can do for you,...
...ask what you can do for your country.
Winston Churchill said, "the destiny of man is not measured by material computations."
"When great forces are on the move in the world,...
...we learn we're spirits, not animals."
And he said, "There's something going on in time and space and beyond time and space,...
...which whether we like it or not, spells duty."